Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO, Folge 106. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO mit Stefan Thigo-Titze und Florentin Vilno-Wolny. Hey, hey, danke. Wie geht's dir denn? Gut, gut, gut, gut, geht so. Ich habe Bock auf eine geile Folge, ich habe Bock auf Kultur, ich habe Bock auf Spaß, ich habe Bock auf ein paar heiße Anekdoten, ich habe Bock auf ein bisschen was Unerwartetes, ich habe Bock auf Gewinnspiel, ich habe Bock auf Preise, auf Siege, auf Hitze, auf Schweiss, auf ein paar Anekdoten, auf Alltag, ich habe Bock auf eine schlechte Folge, möglichst wenig Gags, keine Lacher und Trauer. Das Innerste nach außen kehren, ich will, dass wir heute mal ganz authentisch reden, ich will, dass wir heute auch mal ganz authentisch reden, nicht mehr dieses aufgesetzte, schwierige, das ist ja, kriegst du auch oft diesen Vorwurf, dass du nur eine aufgesetzte Person bist? Ja, wo ich nicht verstehe, weil das kommt offensichtlich von einer Person, die genauso ist, genauso aufgesetzt ist. Weil sowas sagen nur aufgesetzte Leute, weil die nur Filme sowas mal gehört haben. Aber es ist schwer, mit der Kritik umzugehen, wenn du keine Aufgesetzte, also wenn du das nicht absichtlich machst, wenn jemand behauptet, du tust ja immer so, aber dann tut es nicht. Man ist langweilig, im Kern ist man langweilig, uninteressant, boring.
Unkünstlich, im Kern ist es die Aussage, hey, deine Persönlichkeit wirkt künstlich, obwohl sie echt ist.
Weißt du, das ist so wie wenn du, keine Ahnung, du versuchst, auf der anderen Seite Vergleiche.
Du bist nur eine Summe aller Dinge, die du mal jemals gesehen hast.
Das ist geil, das finde ich geil.
Sag das mal in einem coolen Rhythmus.
Du bist die Summe aller Dinge, die du jemals gesehen hast, du bist die Summe aller Dinge, die du jemals konsumiert hast, seine Mutter, dein Vater, sie haben dich beeinflusst, sie haben dich geformt, sie haben dich beeinflusst, deine Umwelt hat dich geformt, Land hat dich geformt, Sprache hat hat dich geformt. Ein bisschen problematisch, denn Deutsch ist ziemlich schwierig und sehr logisch aufgebaut.
Das heißt, Gags funktionieren nicht.
Es gibt spannenden Artikel, danke an Etienne Gardet, der hat mir den geschickt, das ist ziemlich interessant.
Man kann auf Deutsch keine Gags formen.
Keine Gags formen.
Die Sprache ist nicht aufgebaut, dass man damit gut, sagen wir mal, Pants und so kann man damit nicht so gut machen.
Unendlich viele Nachkommastellen hat die Eulersche Zahl, weil sich nichts immer wieder wiederholt, ist sie irrational.
Ich glaube, ich hätte in der Schulzeit nicht gewusst, was irrationale Zahlen sind, wenn es diesen Song nicht gegeben hätte.
Weil sich nichts wiederholt, ist irrational.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, lass uns heute mal eine Shoutout-Folge machen, wo wir einfach über alle Dinge reden, die wir cool finden. Weil es gibt ja so, das Problem ist ja bei so Content-Creators im Internet, ist, dass sie ihren Content-Createn, aber den Created-Content von anderen Content-Creator nicht so unterstützen. Es gibt keinen Support, es gibt zu viel Diss, zu viel Shade, zu viel Beef. Aber wir, wir sagen nein, wir öffnen die Salon-Tür, so dass sie weit nach außen schwingt und dann noch... Ich habe eine Heidenangst vor Saloontür. Ich habe Angst vor Metaphern gerade einfach. Wir schwingen auf wie Saloontür und alles klar. Ey, unentscheidig, in meinem Elternhaus, das Klo unten im Keller ist eine Saloontür. Was, aber wie, aber kann man es abschliessen? Nein, also du kannst den ganzen Raum abschliessen, aber da gibt es halt einen kleinen, kleinen Booth und da drin ist eine Saloontür, die so auf und zu schwingt, wo das Klo drin ist. Was für eine seltsame, blöde Idee.
Ich finde, die Saloon-Tour ist perfekt. Ich glaube, die Saloon-Tour ist der Inbegriff des Westerns, weil du hast automatisch so eine Art Suspense-Moment. Stell dir vor, stiller Raum, Kartenspielen, ja, Derrick Longfinger und seine Bande sitzen in der Kneipe, ja?
Mach mal ein bisschen Atmosphäre.
Und Sergio Leone sitzt in der Ecke.
Mach mal ein bisschen.
Und Ennio Morricone macht die Musik.
Ja.
Und dann spielt jemand auf der Mundharmonika ...
Mach mal ein bisschen Atmosphäre so,
dass die Leute sich das vorstellen.
Also draußen ist so ein Tumbleweed, was ...
Genau, so ein bisschen Kartenspielen irgendwie. Wer steht an der Bar? Im Hintergrund läuft so Musik ... Musik, den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den den so ein weirder Western, wo so ein bisschen versucht wird, deutsche Einflüsse. Es ist kein A-Western, es ist ein B-Western. Und er stürmt durch die Tür und die Flügeltüren gehen wumm, wumm, wumm.
Er will einen coolen Auftritt haben.
Sie gehen ihm, er stösst sie auf, in dem Moment, wo er leider nicht ganz,
nicht genug reingegangen in den Raum.
Das heißt, die Salonen tut ihm wieder entgegen und er ist wieder raus.
Drücken ihn von hinten.
Aber er hat noch eine Chance.
In diesem Szenario tritt jemand ein, der Sonnenschein, die Sonne geht gerade unter,
Licht flutet den Raum und die Tür geht auf und durch die Stille kommt ein Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm, Wamm ganz faszinierend, diese Magneten. Ist das auch immer ein Magneten? Nein, Timing. Timing. Western lebt vom Timing. Und dieses Timing, glaube ich, ist prädestiniert durch diese Saluntür. Ich finde es cool, dass man alle Zeitalter, alle Zeitepochen theoretisch in so kleinen Piktogrammen darstellen kann. Beim Western würde ja reichen diese Sporenstiefel oder ein Pferd oder Pfeil und B oder halt so eine Saluntür. Oder können ja auch Mittelalter sein. Genau, oder Saluntür. Ich glaube, Saluntür ist gut. Okay, gib mir mal das Piktogramm für Etrusker. Klassisch so einfach das große Peace-Zeichen. Ja? Ein großes Joint. Okay, gib mir das Zeichen für Papillonen. Ähm, es ist eine grosse Papyrusrolle. Ja, Ägypter?
Ähm, zwei Papyrusrollen und eine Pyramide, aber hinterher wird angedeutet, das wäre zu einfach. Okay, für griechische Antike? Diese Stiefel von Apollo mit diesem Flügel hinten dran. Okay, die römische Antike? So ein grosser Fuck-you-Finger. Fickt euch einfach, Welt. Die belgische Antike.
Ein grosses Fragezeichen.
Warum haben wir das Fragezeichen bekommen?
Ihr wisst selber nicht, was bei euch war.
Warum ist unsere Flagge ...
Belgische Antike, gibt es das überhaupt?
What about something?
Warum ist unsere Flagge dieser Schulterzugsmiley?
Was versteht ihr denn nicht bei uns? Ihr wisst, ihr sagt immer andere Namen, wenn wir fragen, wo er hier kommt, wie er heisst. Ihr habt komische Outfits an, die nicht sehr kohärent und einheitlich sind. Wir haben noch den Fragebogen ausgefüllt, wir haben die Kultur, wir haben euch unser Lied vorgespielt. Ihr habt den Fragebogen unschlüssig ausgefüllt, viele Dinge sind geschwärzt worden, es ist seltsam, ihr tragt seltsame Dinge. Können wir nicht nochmal anfangen, ich habe das Gefühl, die Weltgeschichte und unser Volk falsch verstanden. Lass uns nochmal ab jetzt neu. Was wollt ihr für eine Flagge haben? Wir dachten halt so dieses wie Glitzer, wie so Pokémon-Karten, so hologrammässig. Geht nicht, wie soll man das darstellen, wenn man Wikipedia über Land googelt, kann da nicht Glitzer sein, das kann man nicht darstellen in CMYK und PHP und GG, das kann man nicht alles darstellen. Es gibt Flaggen, die nicht rechteckig sind. Ja, die Schweizer Flagge ist ein Quadrat. Naja, nicht ganz. Doch, ein quadratisches Quadrat. Ein rechteckiges Quadrat. Halbwissen, I don't know. Was ist deine präferierte geometrische Form? Welche geometrische Form? Oh, lass uns erst mal sagen. Ich bin ein Freund der Symmetrie, also auf jeden Fall schon mal was Symmetrisches. Und jetzt bleibt da nicht mehr viel über, denn die wenigsten sind so. Ich meine, das Parallelogramm fällt schon mal weg. Oh, Paralleloletti, das ist für mich ein absolutes Heightight. Das Parallelogramm war immer so ein Ding. Ich dachte, ich dachte, während Schulzeit dachte ich, wäre das Parallelogramm wesentlich häufiger in meiner Stadt brauchen. Ich dachte, Häuser wären Parallelogramm. Warum sind nicht mal Häuser Parallelogramme? Warum ist es kein, es hat nicht so eine grosse Rolle gespielt im Leben, das Parallelogramm, wie man in der Schulzeit eigentlich stattbekommt. Ich kann fehlerfrei den Flächeninhinhalt von einem Parallelogramm ausrechnen. Oder von einem Trapez. Trapez ist auch kein Ding. Quadrat, Rechteck. Nee, ich bin Quadrat, Quadrat-Fan. Ja, ich würde sagen Kreis. Ich bin Kreis. Also wenn du jetzt sagst zum Beispiel, also lass mal gegenüberstehen, die Flagge der Schweiz und die Flagge von Japan. Welche spricht dich ästhetisch mehr an? Schweiz. Ich würde sagen Japan. Und an der Stelle können wir diesen Podcast dann auch beenden. So, jetzt haben wir nämlich alle Fragen, alle... Das war's. Das ist, glaube ich, der einzige Unterschied zwischen uns beiden. Ich glaube, wir sind uns in allem exakt identisch, wir sehen ein bisschen anders aus, ein bisschen andere Ansichten politisch, und das ist der Unterschied. Interessant, wo würdest du sagen, unterscheiden sich unsere politischen Meinungen? Wir reden so gut wie nie über Politik. Nö.
Wir haben keine Ahnung und drücken das auch nicht aus, aber wo würdest du sagen, unterscheiden wir uns? Also ich sage jetzt mal drei Themen und du sagst mir, bei welchem Thema unsere politischen Meinungen sich am meisten erscheinen.
Alles da.
Thema eins.
Thema eins, Islam, Thema zwei, Frauenrechte und Thema drei, ähm, Außenpolitik. Ganz klar, Außenpolitik. Hängt zusammen. Lächerlicherweise, also mit grossem Abstand Außenpolitik, weil da kannst du vertretbar verschiedene Ansichten haben. Oh, oder nee, lass uns sagen, Islam, Frauen und Nahostkonflikt. Ja, Nahostkonflikt. Da würdest du sagen, sind unsere politischen Meinungen am meisten unterschiedlich. Ich kenne unser beider Wissen, unser beider Background-Wissen bei all diesen Themen, und der ist nicht vorhanden. Und da kann man beim dritten noch zumindest, mit diesem Blendertum, kannst du noch zwei vertretbare Meinungen haben. Eingreifen oder nicht eingreifen. Oder ein bisschen eingreifen oder sich weitestgehend raushalten, aber mal den Finger heben, mahnend. Das sind alles vertretbare Meinungen. Die vertreten auch seriöse Menschen, die so wenig Hintergrundwissen haben wie wir. Aber bei Frauenrechten, all-in-Frauenrechte, würde ich dir zutrauen,
dass du diese ...
Ich würde sagen Race, ich würde sagen Race erst mal.
Erst mal re-race und dann warten, was der andere macht.
Das ist so meine Politik zum Thema Frauenrechte.
Erst wollte ich sagen, aber ich habe grosse Angst vor Politik,
weil erst wollte ich sagen ...
Ich dachte vor Frauen, das auch.
Auch, ich wollte erst sagen, Frauenrechte und Gender,
und dann dachte ich mir, oh, ist es falsch, das gleichzusetzen?
Weil es ist ja nicht das Gleiche, aber kriege ich dann Probleme,
kommt dann der feministische Shitstorm? Egal, ich habe Angst vor dem Thema. Ich will nicht wieder reinsetzen. Ich habe das Gefühl, man kann nur verlieren. Als ich eben auf dich gewartet habe, da habe ich ein Video gesehen. Das taucht bei mir mittlerweile sehr häufig auch bei Facebook, und zwar sind es diese Magierfotos von diesem einen, so einem Strassenmagier, der über die Straße rumläuft und halt Leuten so ein Münzen in dem Ohr hervorzaubert, der Strohhalme in Flaschen versenkt, die zu sind und so, also ein typischer Magier, so ein Strassenmagier. Und die Überschrift, habe ich wahnsinnig gemacht gerade, weil die Überschrift von diesem Video ist People going crazy for fake magic. Zwei Lachsmailies, die mit den Tränen. People going crazy for fake magic. Das ist schon gut. Warum genau fake magic? Und was, glauben die, dass richtige Magic existiert auf einer anderen Welt, in einem anderen Universum? Jesus, warum machst du das? Sorry, ich wollte mich leiser stellen.
Das hast du noch wieder leiser gemacht.
Sorry, ich mach wieder lauter, Entschuldigung.
Ich wollte mich leiser stellen, weil du plärrst wieder so in dein Mikrofon rein, du bist
wieder so echauffiert, wenn es um Magie geht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das bei dir immer so ein Thema ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wo dieses Fake herkommt einfach.
Aber Fake ist echt gut.
Fake Magic.
People going crazy.
Was ist da normale Magic? Ich frage mich aber, ob wir uns magiemässig weiterentwickeln. Wahrscheinlich schon, ne? Weil ich mein, du bist ja schon limitiert zu, also was Kartentricks angeht. Ist man da, also welcher... Ich glaub, mich kann immer weniger beeindrucken, weil mich immer mehr beeindruckt. Beispiel, man kann mittlerweile, gibt es Globusse, die schweben, weil die so Magnetfelder bilden, das schwebt einfach. Okay, es gibt Blumentöpfe, die schweben. Aber die schweben auf so einem Podest, die schweben nicht einfach im Raum. Ne, da ist dann so ein, genau, da ist dann so ein grosses Magnetding drunter und schweben, ja, gut, okay, alles klar, Herr Professor. Ich wollte es nur noch klarstellen. Weil da unten drin Pole, ja, flasse Erklärung, weil da unten drin zwei Pole sich abstßen, dann ist da oben so ein, ja. Mir ging es einfach nur darum. Das ist eine Erklärung, weil da zwei Pole drin sind, die sich abstoßen. Man kann mit dir echt nicht über Magnete reden. Das ist ja eine Erklärung dafür immer. Machen wir einfach diesen Unschuss für die Unschuss nicht. Und dann, solche Sachen gibt es mittlerweile. Oder man kann mit Elektroautos einmal um die Welt fahren, so gefühlt, und dann, okay, dann zerschneidet halt einfach so ein Typ eine Jungfrau mit einer Säge. Und dann sage ich, okay, ich weiß nicht, wie du es gemacht hast, aber es gibt so viele Sachen mittlerweile, so viele technische Fortschritte und so. Flugzeuge sollen mittlerweile, sollen innen drin, sollen keine Fenster mehr haben, sondern sollen innen drin so große Videoscreens haben. Oh ja. Und damit man außen die Welt sieht. Aber das finde ich blöd. Ich will das nicht sehen durch ein Videoscreen. Ich will die große Fenster. Du kannst den Boden sehen, weil der Boden eine Video-Wall ist. Ja, aber dann kann ich mich auch in den Raum setzen und muss nicht fliegen und habe die Monitore. Ich will doch die echte Welt sehen und nicht einen Monitor. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Ich will auch eigentlich sagen, dass es ja super unterstützenswert ist, aber es gibt so viele crazy Sachen gerade, dass ich mich Magie glaube ich nicht mehr beeindrucken kann, weil, ja gut, da ist halt irgendwas technisch, hochtechnisiertes, was du da gerade gemacht. Also ich mag ja verlieren an Stellenwert, je besser, je technisierter die Welt ist, wann nicht. Ich will mehr Statistiken sehen, so worin Menschen immer besser werden,
zum Beispiel so Marathonläufer,
die wurden immer besser,
immer besser, immer besser, immer schneller, immer schneller,
immer schneller und dann ist es so ein bisschen
abgeflacht, wo man sagt,
okay, man erreicht, also man nähert sich dem
Nullpunkt der menschlichen maximalen Leistungsfähigkeit
und irgendwann ist man da vielleicht
oder man kratzt dann halt immer noch so ein bisschen drüber, aber im Grunde ist man irgendwann da. Und es gab eine Zeit, wo es ganz schnell besser wurde, weil die Leute hatten immer bessere Schuhe und immer mehr Lust, mehr Laune, mehr Laune am Laufen, L am L. Ich frage mich, wann wird Sport egal, weil es irgendwann Menschen gibt, die auf dem Mars geboren sind zum Beispiel, weil die Erdanziehungskraft nicht so groß ist, die Marsanziehungskraft, deswegen sind die grösser geworden, weil die Wirbelsäule halt einfach sich anders entwickelt, wenn du halt weniger nach unten gezogen wirst. Und wenn die dann auf die Erde kommen, weil einfach krass gut im Weitspringen sind. Okay, der Sport ist einfach Geschichte. Ja, das stimmt. So du als Mensch hast du, schau mal vor, du bist ein Mensch, trainierst dein Leben lang Weitspringen und plötzlich kommt so die Marskolonie und testet das mal. Und so der erste Typ, so ein zwölfjähriger Junge, testet das dann mal aus und springt einfach 80 Meter weit. Ich meine, so ist es doch jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen, oder? Dass eine gewisse Herkunft natürlich dich schon prädestiniert für gewisse Sportarten. Also du willst damit sagen, dass Männer, dass Frauenfußball kein richtiger Sport ist? Das willst du jetzt damit sagen? Ja, das will ich damit sagen. Jede Woche kommt das so raus. Ich weiß, ich liebe einfach meinen Fusi. Ich liebe nichts mehr als meinen Fusi. Und ich will nicht, dass wir denn irgendwelche Frauen wegnehmen. Da krieg ich es wieder anzutun. Jeden Samstag du mit einem Bierchen vom Fusi, ne? Da kann man dich ja nicht stören. Ich weiß, ich nehme das schon wahr, was da um mich herum passiert, so auf einer Ebene, aber ich bin voll drin.
Ich bin bei Messi, ich bin bei Totti, ich bin bei Louis Buffon und ich bin einfach drin.
Alles richtig auf eine gute Art.
Ich sag mal, sehe ich Louis Buffon, ignoriere ich das Telefon. Das ist bei mir so ...
Buffon statt Telefon.
Ich kann dann auch keine guten Wortspiele machen,
weil sich meine gesamte Leistungsfähigkeit auf den Fernseher registriert.
Das ist schon was Besonderes.
Ja, ist was Besonderes, aber es ist einfach meine zweite Natur, einfach so meine Heimat irgendwie, da bin ich zu Hause.
Du gehst ja auch im Wochenende in den Schimmerpölen mit den Jungs auf den Platz, schön Kicken.
Ich habe für viele Dinge keine Toleranz, aber ich glaube, wofür ich am allerwenigsten Toleranz habe, ist Grölen. Im Allgemeinen. Grölen. Und allein schon, wenn ich dann irgendwie so im Zug bin und es grölt einer aus dem Nebenraum, da kommt er mir. Interessante Wortwahl, auch weil die so ein bisschen, die schon negativ konnotiert. Ja. Also wie schon so ein Du, Du. Du versuchst maximal laut zu sprechen. Ja. Also das hast du dir erklärt im Lexikon, grölen gleich maximal laut sprechen, ohne auch noch einen Hauch von Ästhetik im Sound zu haben. Nein, nein, nein, das ist Schreien, Brölen oder Rufen. Grölen hingegen ist ein gesangsartiger, lauter Sprechakt, der vor allem dazu gedacht ist, alle Leute zu nerven, die gerade keinen Bock auf Gröhen haben.
Singen zum Beispiel. Wenn jemand singt und der andere singt nicht, dann sagt er, gut, der singt halt so.
Gröhen ist aber intrusive, der kommt an dich ran, ob du willst oder nicht.
Und deswegen, hey, das war Rufen.
Hey, Gröhen, ja, Gröhen, haben wir's, haben wir's, haben wir's, komm. Ja, das stimmt, das ist unangenehm, ne? Das ist absolut unangenehm. Der Brunftschrei ist einfach ein Mannes. Das wäre eine sozioökologische Studie. Wie läuft so Dating bei so Vögeln ab?
Gefieder, Gefieder ist auf eins.
Es gibt ja eine Aussensicht, so dass du als Mensch siehst du die Vögel und sagst,
ah ja, die haben hier einen Paarungstanz und dann passiert das und dann bauen die ihr Nest und dann bringt der ihr Äste und blub.
Aber als Mensch nimmt man das nicht so wahr, was jemand von außen wahrnehmen könnte, wenn er dich wie ein Tier beobachten würde. Natürlich gibt es Menschen, die sich selber analysieren, aber du bist ja trotzdem immer so, steckst ja drin. Deswegen als Mensch sagst du, oh ja, so Dating-Tipps, so hey, bravo, sprich sie an, aber von der Aussensicht ist es vielleicht ganz anders wahrnehmbar. Und so bei den Vögeln, die vielleicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ja das Männchen drückt dem Weibchen irgendwie einen toten Wurm in den Schlund,
aber so in der Vogelwelt ist es so, ja die Ramona irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, es läuft nicht so ganz mit der irgendwie,
aber irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, irgendwie, es will nicht so funktionieren irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ich habe jetzt schon den toten Wurm in den Rachen gedrückt, ich habe jetzt schon die Stöcke gegeben,
hast du noch ein paar Tipps, du hast da immer so viel Erfolg bei den Frauen, so was soll ich machen? Das ist genau mein Tipp, hörst du da, das ist der Manfred. So, du musst... Du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du Nein, ohne Scheiss. Ramona ist eine anspruchsvolle Frau, die hat studiert, die kann man nicht mit solchen dummen Tricks um den Finger wickeln.
Ramona steht auch nur auf deinem prallen Gröl-Apparat. Die will, dass du auf dem hohen Ton, das macht die Frau total rallig. Ich probier's mal, okay? Immer dran denken. Hey Ramona!
Hey, na?
Du, ähm...
Oh, das war auch ein schönes Gefieder.
Du hast so ein leicht... Brr, brr, brr, brr. Hey, Ramona! Hey, na?
Du, ähm ... Oh, das war auch ein schönes Gefieder. Du hast so einen leicht ... Ja. So einen grünlichen Schimmer auf deinem Kopf. Du, ich, ähm ... Wir kennen uns jetzt schon eine Weile, und ich dachte mir irgendwie, weil wir ja letztens auch einen ganz schönen Abend hatten, dachte ich mir vielleicht ... Das ist mein Lieblingssong. Das ist mein absoluter Lieblingssong. Nee. Wow wow, ich will sofort auf dieser Stelle mit dir schlafen. Toll, das wäre toll, ne, also so Bonhoff-Trei, warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt? Auch in Amerika habe ich Tauben gehört und die sind. Was ist denn bei dir, hast du jetzt wieder so eine Ornithologenphase bei dir da was.
Da könntest du ohne weiteres so einen Trapbeat machen.
Die enden immer auf diesem ... Also es ist nicht die Eins.
Over.
Das ist over.
Ich bin raus.
Das ist nicht die Eins.
Also wenn du Musikmässig rangehen würdest, das ist ... Da, da, da, da, da, da, da ... Es ist sogar nicht mal ein Viervierteltakt. Da, eins, da, da ... Boah, das ist gleich ein Fünffierteltakt oder sowas. Kann mal irgendwer den Sound der Vögel ... Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, dagel ... ... Ganz abgefahren. Und das sieht auch immer nicht auf der Eins enden, sondern auf diesem hohen Zipfelchen da. Ganz strange ist das. Ganz komisch. Warum haben wir uns nicht die Musik von den Vögeln abgeschaut? Ich glaube, das ist auch passiert. Meinst du? Ja. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ja, freilich. Die Menschen haben auch alles nur geklaut. Oder? Also die Menschen sind so ein bisschen so, die Menschen sind die des China der Natur. Die haben nichts eigenes hervorgebracht, klauen alles, aber sind damit erfolgreicher als die jeweiligen Individuen. Auch Rassismus. Ja, Musik geklaut von Vögeln, Fliegen geklaut von Vögeln, sich warme Sachen anzuziehen im Winter geklaut von Vögeln. Es ist im Grunde, sind Menschen die schlechteren Vögel. Ich habe neulich die antiklimatische Sendung aller Zeiten gesehen. Das ist eine Dokumentationsreihe auf Netflix. Über den Yeti. Wie jemand den Yeti sucht. Und dann haben die es, die haben es wieder versucht, nicht natürlich, dass sie hingerauen, die haben es wieder versucht, es seriös aussehen zu lassen mit einem richtigen Wissenschaftler, dem die dann die ganzen Haarproben, die die ganzen Länder sammeln, Nepal, Tibet usw. sammeln, dem geben die dann und dann untersucht er das.
Und alle Länder da um die, speziell da um Nepal und so rum, auch Südalpen und so, die haben alle diese Yeti-Sage und alle reden von dem Yeti. Und das heißt überall ein bisschen anders, aber alle haben das von diesem Bär-ähnlichen, grossen, auf zwei Beinen laufenden Geschöpf sprechen die. Da dachte ich mir, wow, cool, cool, cool, löst es auf, was ist der Yeti, gibt es sowas? Und das sind viel zu hohe Gegenden, wo eigentlich gar keine so grossen Tiere mehr existieren würden, wo auch Reinhold Messner diesen grossen Abdrück mal fotografiert hat und den auch mal gesehen hat und so weiter. Und dann die Nazis haben auch immer einen gefangen und so ein Bullshit. Und dann am Ende kommt raus, haben die halt alle diese Haarproben den Wissenschaftler rausgeschickt und dann fährt der Typ dahin, ist irgendwo in England und es kommt raus, ich muss dir was sagen, Joe, alle Haarproben kommen von dem gleichen Geschöpf, ist ein Tier und ist tatsächlich verwandt mit den Bären und du wirst nicht glauben, was für ein Bär es ist, ein Eisbär. So, jetzt sitze ich da, vor dieser acht Stunden Dokumentation, habe mir die ganze Zeit, das hättet ihr in drei Minuten auch klären können. Angreibend saß ich da und dachte mir, what, es gibt offensichtlich ein Yeti und diese Billo-Dokumentation löst gerade auf, was der Yeti ist und es ist ein fucking Eisbär und hat das irgendeine wissenschaftliche Beglaubigung, selbst das wäre eine Erkenntnis. Und dann kam am Ende raus, dass es eine Kreuzung ist zwischen Braunbären und Eisbären. Die Eisbären gehen nicht mehr weiter südlich, die Braunbären nicht mehr weiter nördlich. So Schoko-Eisbären. Und dann gibt es halt so eine Mischung. Und dann müsst ihr euch vorstellen, wie das Glas Milch und der Schokoriegel aus der Werbung, dem Kinderriegel, dann kommen die wieder näher, liegen, lieben sich, hardcore die ganze Zeit ordentlich, den Lörris wird reingehalten, und dann kommt da raus der Yeti. Und dann denke ich, das ist jetzt eure Erklärung oder was? Und dann Abspann, zehn Minuten. Aber Moment mal, halten sich nicht immer Yetis und Sith in der Waage eigentlich? Also muss es ja nicht auch ein Sith geben? Aber ganz kurz. Ja, aber das ist nur ein Vogel, irgendeine Vogelart. Es gibt ja im Internet die Rule 34, die besagt, also es gibt so die Regeln des Internets, hat irgendjemand mal aufgestellt und da gibt es halt so ganz viele Regeln. Und unter anderem die Regel, ich glaube es ist 34, also 34, und die besagt, there's porn of it. Das bedeutet, egal was es gibt auf der Welt, es gibt davon eine Porno-Variante. Das ist die Regel 34? Richtig. Egal was es gibt. Wie viele Regeln gibt es? So 50 ungefähr, sowas in der Richtung. Das heißt, keine Ahnung, du schaust gerade irgendeine tolle Serie, was weiss ich, du schaust gerade Rick and Morty, there is porno a bit. Es gibt eine Rick and Morty Porno-Edition. Gibt es auch von diesem Kinderriegel, von diesem Schokoriegel und dem Milchglas, gibt es da eine Porno? Nö, glaube ich gar nicht, oder? Ich glaube nicht, dass das ist. Also Europa vielleicht. Ich denke immer, das wäre eine deutsche Marke, weil es Kinder heißt. Ich glaube, es ist ja auch ursprünglich deutsch, aber mittlerweile halt Ferreiro. Naja, aber das ist eine, glaube ich schon. Ich glaube, es gibt wirklich von allem Porno. Es gibt wirklich, egal was ihr konsumiert, sucht mal das, was ihr gerade konsumiert, Porno, es gibt es hundertprozentig. Aber ist das Glas dann nicht undicht? Du bist so ein versauter Lümmel manchmal, sitzt hier mit einer Halberektion und Podcast hier. Wo soll denn der Schokoman sein? Diese Pornomacher werden sehr kreativ von diesem Porn. Marge ist unfassbar heiß in diesen Pornos. Absolut. Ja, vor allem auch so straight ... Sorry, Marge und Lisa. Ich weiß, Lisa ist ein bisschen zu jung mit ihren zwölf Jahren, viel zu jung, acht Jahre, viel zu jung, aber heiß. So heiß. Vor allem, ja, mal abgesehen von 34-Porno, auch Pädophilie an der Stelle. Also nebenbei, bei den Simpsons, sobald Maggie im Spiel ist, ist es einfach merkwürdig. Sobald Maggie im Spiel ist, mache ich auch aus. Das geht mir zu weit. Lisa, okay, Bart, heißer Body, aber alles darunter, nope. Ist schon spannend, oder? Das Internet ist, viele Leute fragen einen ja immer und es ist ja die grosse, langweilige, ongoing Diskussion, ist das Internet gut für die Menschen oder nicht gut für die Menschen, die es wirklich ein für alle mal klären, floh und hin will. Gut. Ist es gut oder schlecht für die Menschen? Gut für die Menschen auf jeden Fall. Aber die Anonymität und was das alles mit Menschen macht und dieses Cybermobbing und Kinderpornos und Leute verbreiten sich, radikalisieren sich. Das Internet ist immer ein Spiegel der Gesellschaft. Und du hast jetzt zum Beispiel gerade gesagt Anonymität. Dann sollte ich mir jetzt eher die Frage stellen, warum müssen Menschen nicht überhaupt anonym agieren? Warum können sie denn nicht offen agieren? Warum haben sie denn Angst, mit ihrem eigenen Namen zu agieren? Ist das nicht das eigentliche Problem, dass man auch in der Öffentlichkeit einfach sagen könnte, mein Name ist Klaus Fritzel-Meisel und du bist eine dumme Fotze! Warum geht sowas nicht in unserer Gesellschaft? Warum wird man da gleich nur angezogen? Die dumme Fotze kommt dann an und schlägt dir einfach in die Fresse. Ja, gut. Ich meine ja nur, im Endeffekt... War aber auch nicht die Frage. Ich sag mal, im Endeffekt muss man mal drüber nachdenken. So Anne will eineinhalb Stunden Talkshow und am Ende merkt einer ja, aber doch schon Grund und Boden argumentiert und er merkt auch selber. Hat bei jemanden so eine Diskussion einfach verloren und würde der danach auch sagen, jupp, sorry, ich finde nach einer Talkshow sollte es so Interviews geben, so wie war es da draußen für dich, wie war, stell dir mal die Talkshow vor, wo halt dann irgendwie so ein AfD-Typ dabei ist und dann halt irgendwie so ein anderer und dann der AfD-Typ nach drei Minuten, ja stimmt eigentlich, du hast echt recht, sorry, das war, und auf einmal, was passiert im Rest der Sendung, was passiert im Rest der Sendung, sobald ein, die reden über Fussball, eine Einheit da ist und dann so, nee, du hast recht, stimmt, Flüchtlinge sind eigentlich eine Bereicherung für uns. Aber alle argumentieren ja so, als sei das ein logisches Ergebnis, ein potenzielles Ergebnis der Diskussion. Alle argumentieren ja immer so und reden immer so, als ob sie, die wollen ja den anderen beeinflussen, die wollen ja nicht das Publikum für sich gewinnen, sondern man streitet ja miteinander und will den anderen beeinflussen und will dem anderen helfen, quasi das Licht zu sehen und die richtigen Erkenntnisse zu bekommen, als sei das eine logische Möglichkeit, dass der andere sagt, jo, ja, eigentlich hast du die ganze Zeit recht. Naja, Jan, die Leih wirst du nie überzeugen. Aber ich finde, am Ende sollte man so einen so viel Reporter geben, die fragen, so jetzt Wolfram Kuppicki, wie war es für dich da draußen? Willis, Willis. Ja, klar. Gut, in der Atemstattstattstunde ein bisschen gehen lassen, da haben wir den Gegner ein bisschen kommen lassen, aber dann im zweiten Hälfte, gut, da war einmal kurz, da war dann die Werbepause, aber danach habe ich doch gut angegriffen, bin drangeblieben und habe das Ding locker nach Hause gefahren. Das war eine richtig gute Wolfgang Kubicki Impression, also das war wirklich spot on mein Lieber. Ich arbeite an so ein paar Impressionen, leider kennt man die meisten nicht gut genug. Mach mal Morty. Salvador Dalí habe ich am Start, aber von dem weiß leider niemand genau, wie er spricht, ausser dass er eine fremde Sprache spricht.
Mach mal Caligula.
Sissi!
Alter, das ist so geil, als Sessel vor mir.
Prego!
Das ist so geil, Alter.
Rick and Morty, kann ich gut, Achtung, Rick.
Hey, hey Morty, hey, hey Morty!
Das ist das Einzige, was er immer sagt.
Und Morty ist immer, yeah, yeah, what up, yo, Rick, hey, Rick! Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht, finde ich nicht gut. Er applaudiert sich selbst, ich bin nicht der Eke. Es flunt ihn, flunt ihn applaudiert mir. Nein, Stefan applaudiert sich selbst. Er hält seine Hände zusammen, er behauptet dabei, ich bin's nicht, ich bin's nicht, niemand sieht uns. Ich lege meine Hände aufs Mikrofon, nein, das sind nicht meine Hände, könnt ihr vergessen.
Ich muss sagen, aus dem Nürnstrich hat er so ein bisschen Antibiotikum.
Es ist die, diese Storyline wird uns immer begleiten weiterhin und ich werde es ja auch nicht los, es bleibt dabei.
Letzte Woche habe ich euch erzählt, ich habe mein Boosted-Bot finally bekommen, ich habe es ausprobiert, super cool, dann habe ich es beim zweiten Mal ausprobiert, direkt in die zweite Stufe gegangen und es ist lächerlich schnell, es ist wirklich unfassbar schnell, man düst durch die Welt, ich bin bei mir um den Block gefahren hier in Köln und Leute gucken, ein älteres, älteres Ehepaar ist stehen geblieben und hat mir so hinterher geguckt, wie in so einem Simpsons Vorspann, wo Bart mit dem Skateboard durch Springfield düst und so Leute stehen bleiben und gucken und sind sauer und sie haben hinterher geguckt und Leute haben angehalten, weil es ist auch ziemlich laut, das ist lauter, als ich dachte. Es war auch die ganze Zeit so ein Geräusch. Und dann bin ich halt da rumgefahren und dann wurde ich halt immer sicherer, selbstsicherer und dann kam auch so eine Gruppe entgegen und dann musste ich auch so ein bisschen lachen, weil es so ein bisschen lustig halt aussieht, wie man da rumfährt. Und dann kam halt so eine Baustelle und ich sah nur so einen Haufen Schotter im Weg liegen und da habe ich halt gebremst, ganz doll. Ich wusste aber nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt, wie gut diese Bremsen funktionieren, weil die sind sehr sicher, weil du kannst sehr schnell fahren, also musst du auch schnell bremsen können. Ich habe also die Bremse gedrückt, das ist instant stehen geblieben. Ich dachte mir, fuck, versuch also weiter zu rennen, in der Geschwindigkeit, wie ich vorher gefahren bin, zu rennen, keine Chance, umgefallen und mit meinem Ellenbogen und meinem Knie schön über den Schotter geratscht. Und das hat sich jetzt entzündet mit meinem Arm. Ich war heute Morgen zum ersten Mal seit drei Jahren, zum ersten Mal in Köln, war ich beim Arzt, wo ich morgens zählt, ich wusste gar nicht, wie es geht, rufe ich da vorher an, muss ich einen Termin machen, kann ich da einfach hingehen? Und dann war ich morgens da und dann kam ich direkt dran und jetzt habe ich Antibyldikum bekommen. Das heißt, jetzt spricht gerade die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen Antibyldikum aus mir.
Ey, Stefan saß gestern den ganzen Tag im Büro und meinte so, oh, ich habe Fieber und mir geht es auch nicht gut.
Ich habe Fieber.
Hängt das zusammen mit meiner Wunde, das entzündet sich und dann googelt, googelt, googelt, oh, mir geht es nicht gut, ich habe schon ein bisschen Fieber, guck mal, ob ich Fieber habe.
Du hast gesagt, du hast schon ein bisschen Fieber.
Ja, du hast ein bisschen Fieber, hast du, aber auch weil du dir selber den Kopf machst. Und dann, oh, mir geht's nicht gut, oh, mir ist ganz schwindelig, oh, ich muss was essen, ich hab Durst, ich muss was machen, ich muss zum Arzt, ich gehe zum Apotheker, den ganzen Tag, ey, wegen seiner winzigen Wunde da. Und heute hat er gesagt, sie sind lebensgefährlich verletzt, nehmen sie dieses Antibiotikum, sofort, und dann kommen sie nie wieder Und dann habe ich halt dieses Antibiotikum genommen und jetzt muss ich den ganzen Tag daran denken, an diesen Satz, es spricht das Antibiotikum aus mir, es spricht der Alkohol aus mir, sagt man ja so. Wenn Leute sagen, wenn Leute irgendwie offen sind und dann was getrunken haben, sagen die, oh sorry, der Alkohol spricht aus mir. Und wir wissen alle, wie der Alkohol klingt, so. Wir wissen alle,ohol ist ein Arschloch, das tief blicken lässt. Ein Riesenwichser, ein zu ehrlicher Wichser. Antibiotikum spricht immer so ein bisschen Lallen, so ein bisschen zu müde, so ein bisschen irgendwas ist gerade mit dir nicht in Ordnung. Aber warum will man als Mensch nicht wissen, wie andere Dinge sprechen? Wie spricht so eine Fichte aus einem oder so? Ja. Wenn du mal einfach so schön so eine Fichte injizierst. Ich will wissen, wie so eine Zucker. Du weißt auch, wie Zucker aus dir spricht. Absolut. Du, aufgedreht, die ganze Zeit alles ein bisschen übersteuert, das ganze Mikrofon, ist die ganze Zeit ein bisschen zu nah dran. Ja, so klingt Zucker einfach so. Hallo Leute, ich bin ja schon da, was können wir machen, wo ist das Fahren, wo ist mein Fahren? Was soll ich machen? Äh, äh, ist das halt ein Torregel?
Und Koffein spricht die ganze Zeit auch ein bisschen zu schnell aus dir und auch ein bisschen zu laut und zu nervig.
Wohingegen zu viel Nudeln gegessen klingt eher so...
Hey Leute.
Jabba.
Auch so ein bisschen weit weg, eine grosse Nudel.
Hey Leute, könnt ihr mir kurz ein bisschen aufhelfen?
Ey, kannst du mir kurz meine Schuhe geben, bitte?
Oh, ich hab... Oh, ich ich hab euch weiß nicht gras spricht so
aus dir mdma spricht so aus dir hier hier einfügen was wir haben dem marken Ecstasy ist das gleiche.
Wir haben noch nie Drogen genommen, ich habe es erfahren. Crystal Meth spricht so aus dir.
Also selbstbewusst wahrscheinlich und so.
Also das ist schon interessant, aber man weiss nicht genau, wie spricht ein Delfin aus dir?
Oder wie spricht Werner Herzog aus dir?
Aber Werner Herzog, aus Werner Herzog spricht ein Delfin. Aus Werner Herzog spricht ein Delfin. Das muss immer der Aus, Werner Herzog spricht, immer irgendwas anderes raus. Ja, aber das ist genau was ich mir frage. Es ist auch interessant, dass man als Menschheit versucht, mit intelligenten Lebensformen ausserhalb Kontakt aufzunehmen, den Schallplatten von Black-Eyed-Piece-Siekt und so weiter und Mozart. Let's get it started. Ich stelle mir immer so eine Mars-Kolonie, also so eine Alien-Kolonie vor. Don't you know, bump it up. Nicht von den Bergen. Let's get it started. Let's get it started. In here. Und die ganzen Aliens werden in der Heben ihre dreiwärlichen Hände hoch. Das eine Auge, gross aufgerissen. Mit pelztenen und die Sulfatatmosphäre, alles stieg ein bisschen hoch. Und das, was die als Licht waren, die Lightshow, die die als Licht wahrnehmen, was wir aber nur als Ultra-Leonette verschwinden. Wir leben 12.000 Jahre, let's get it started, let's get it started, so gut einfach. Vorhin sind trotzdem drüber. Ja, und mit denen wollen wir halt irgendwie unsere Gedanken teilen und mit denen sprechen und wollen uns den Kontakt aufnehmen.
Aber intelligentes Leben auf der, gestern ist es ja verboten, an Oktopussen das Gehirn aufzuschneiden, wenn man, wenn die nicht, oder generell Operationen durchzuführen, wenn die nicht unter Betäubung sind, weil die so intelligent sind. Und wenn sie es selber wollen? Ja, da müssen Sie vorher so eine Bedaube unterschreiben. Aber die sind so intelligent, dass man nicht an denen ohne Anästhesist arbeiten darf. Und mit denen will man nicht sprechen oder was? Mit denen will man nicht mehr Kontakt aufnehmen so. Mit Aliens willst du sprechen, aber Tiere sind dir scheißegal. So, Oktopus, warum willst du hier mal ... Wir können doch mal lernen, mit dem Delfin zu sprechen. So, deren Gehirnwellen. Ich glaube, da hat der Mensch Angst davor. Stell dir mal vor, wir können... Aber warum ist das Paradox? Aber ganz im Ernst, wenn es tatsächlich...
Ich glaube, da hat der Mensch Angst davor. Stell dir mal vor, wir könnten wirklich... Aber warum ist das Paradox? Aber ganz im Ernst, wenn es tatsächlich... Ich glaube, das wird noch ein Riesenthema in den nächsten 100 Jahren. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Angenommen, wir können wirklich Tieren so einen Helm aufsetzen, dann können die sprechen, dann haben wir ein richtiges Problem. Weil dann kommst du nicht... Dann hast du ein Tierschutzproblem. Weil wir alle diesen Helm wollen. Weil wir alle den Helm wollen und dann hast du keine Chance mehr mit dieser Tierhaltung und so, kannst du alles vergessen, weil die Tierschützer halt die Oberhand haben und dann können die, dann heißt es, dürfen die dann wählen, wen wählen die, gibt es denn eigene Tierparteien, das ist ein riesiges, ist ein echtes Problem. Dürfen Wale wählen, dürfen allein wegen des Witzes Wale wählen. Ja, Bundestagswahl.
Darf ich zur Wahl?
Bundestagswahl, Wahl.
Naja, aber ich finde es... Ja, Bundestagswahl. Darf ich zur Wahl?
Naja.
Aber ich finde es schon paradox.
Ich glaube, dann gibt es Kriege vielleicht zwischen Tier und Mensch.
Weil der Mensch lässt sich doch nicht reinreden, auch in seiner Politik oder so von Tieren.
Also klar, es gibt manche Menschen. Tieren sind uns ja auch nicht, also die sind uns ja offensichtlich zurück.
Ja gut, aber das kannst du ja von so einem ...
So einem Esel.
Nein.
Aber ist ja ...
Ich meine ...
Klar, natürlich gibt es ein paar Menschen,
die sagen, ja, wir sollten auf die Tiere hören und so,
aber der Grossteil wird doch sagen,
fickt euch und dann gibt es Krieg.
Ich glaube auch, es gibt Krieg. Aber ich finde es schon faszinierend, Tiere sind den Menschen scheissegal, offensichtlich. So, nö, wir suchen noch andere Lebewesen im All, nö, nö, aber wir sind noch mehrere von uns. Hey Leute, hier im Wasser gibt's noch genug Tiere, die wir nicht entdeckt haben. Wir haben manche versteckt, im Ariangraben, der ist nämlich tief. Der ist richtig tief. Hey, guck mal, ich hab ein Boot, wir können mit meinem Boot fahren. Nope, nope. Wir haben mein Boot hier. Wir reisen durchs unendlich gefährliche All mit einem Spaceship. Braucht ihr nicht! Wir haben noch ein Boot, ich hab so ein Tauch. Aber wir nennen es Schip. Taucherglar. Aber Raumschip. Ich hab ein echtes Schiff hier. Nee, nee, nee. Warum denn? Das ist so einfach. Ich will da oben die weit weg sind, die wir nach unseren physikalischen Gästen niemals erreichen können. Da will ich hin. Mit denen will ich sprechen.
Nicht mit dem scheiss achtarmigen Geschöpf.
So eine Taucherglocke, ey. Alter Vater. Ist sie aber auch nach unten zu?
Schon, ne? Das ist nicht wie eine echte Glocke. Sie ist auch nach unten zu, oder?
Ich habe die Heizung.
Ich sage nur Glocke.
Ich sage nur Glocke. Aber ich verstehe dich, dass sie dich zerreißt.
Weil du drückst ja von unten, dann bist du ja auch tot, wenn der Druck zu hoch ist. Welcher Mensch ist auf die Idee gekommen, dass es clever ist, mit einem Käfig ins Meer zu steigen, um dann mit Haien interagieren zu? Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung. Warum war das nicht die Methode, sich vor anderen zu... Also so eine Ritterrüstung ist ja teuer und aufwendig. Auch da kann man einfach einen Käfig nehmen. Oder auf diesem Käfig, so Rollen dran und dann einfach irgendwie Battle of Hastings oder so. Hast du halt so einen grossen Käfig und alle so, geht nix. Das Problem ist, dass beide Parteien bei diesem Käfig angekommen und dann halt das Einzige ist, man konnte den Gegner ein bisschen pieksen vielleicht. Oder so umwerfen, so ausmanövrieren und dann so umwerfen. Ich glaube, man stellt sich das auch bei Game of Thrones, gestern wieder, hast du ja gerade erzählt, eine grosse Schlacht im Fernsehen, so eine grosse Schlacht gezeigt. Ich glaube, man romantisiert das dann auch. Ich glaube, die echten Schlachten, aber da bist du jetzt so wieder lächerlich gut informiert, aber im Mittelalter, die waren nicht so geil. Ich glaube, die sahen nicht so cool aus wie da. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, es war, ich glaube, so Asterix bei den Galliern, nee, das macht keinen Sinn, bei diesem, da wurde die dann mit dieser Schildkröten-Taktik, mit diesen lächerlichen Formationen, das macht schon Sinn. Ja. So lächerlich war das, glaube ich, auch. So stelle ich mir das vor. Ja. Oder wie wir ein Schlachten. Für uns mal bitte durch dein Wissen. Es kommt halt darauf an, ein bisschen welche Zeit, aber ansonsten sind solche Schildwallstrategien sind natürlich schon eine interessante Sache. Das ist ja auch immer so das Tolle bei so einem Mittelalterfilm, hast du ja oft so zwei Armeen, die Schildwelle haben, und dann aber kurz bevor sie sich treffen, brechen die aus ihrer Formation raus und rennen auf die Gegner zu. Das dümmste ist der Welt. Was ist so, okay, einerseits man hat der Geschichte Rechnung getragen, wenn man sagt, ja, die haben schon Schildwahl, aber sie benutzen die dann nicht, was schon ein bisschen merkwürdig ist. Was ich mir zum Beispiel auch immer denke, mein größtes Problem ist, ist das Gelände, dass so Schlachten oft inszeniert werden auf riesigen Feldern, freien Flächen. Wo sind denn? Also solche Flächen gibt es schon, aber also ich meine zum Beispiel auch sämtliche Wälder, in denen du und ich jemals waren, sind nicht natürlich. Sie sahen nicht so aus wie vor im Mittelalter. Da waren die viel dichter, ganz anders und heute sind die halt durch Forstwirtschaft und so, damit die gesund sind und so. Und Felder und so sind ja auch im Phänomen. Kaplett überwuchert und so. Ja, aber Felder gab's ja, Landwirtschaft gab's ja.
Ja, aber nicht so wie heute und so auf licht und felder und so sind ja auch im phänomen und so ja aber felder gab es ja landwirtschaft gab es ja aber nicht so wie heute und so auf fältern aber die waren auch nicht so groß glaube ich also ich meine du hast ja dann tatsächlich dich selber versorgt ich weiß es nicht genau und gras ist ja auch so ein ding so ein menschending also ich glaube damals bei den dinos und so da gab es ja keine gras also es gab ja keine graslandschaften weil gras ist ja was was die menschen womit die menschen angefangen haben, das zu verbreiten und weil die halt diese Freifläche brauchen. Und auch die Koordination, dass man sich genau auf so einem Feld dann trifft, irgendwie mit der anderen Armee, die ja auch, und dann hast du so Kundschafter und so schon. Sorry, wir sind jetzt am Wald hier jetzt gewesen. Wir sind bei der grossen Klippe. Was, die grosse, wir haben noch gesagt am Wald hier, bei dem Burn äh, bei dem Bernhard. Nee, wir haben gesagt die Klippe mit dem, mit dem, mit dem, beim Rudi, ich bin bei Rudi. Wir hatten gesagt an der Hütte mit Bernhard, da in dem grossen Wald, wo die Tannen sind. Ich habe jetzt hier alle Männer, wir rasten seit drei Tagen einfach, zehntausend Männer sind hier. Sorry. Uns gehen auch die, die rasten, wir haben auch kein Essen mehr, wir sind alle am Hungern, wir sind alle schwach, verletzbar. Sorry, komplett falsch, komplett falsch. Vor allem, ich glaube, dass man rückwirkend auch viele Dinge vertuscht, die nicht cool waren. Also klar, was heute noch erhalten ist, die coolen Ritterrüstungen mit den Gravuren und die Waffen und so und dann die ersten Pistolen und so. Sehr interessant, erste Pistolen-Designs habe ich im Metropolitan Museum gesehen, so ganz verrückt auch, so wie die Griffe angeordnet waren und so. Also wenn man das Ergebnis kennt, dann sieht es lächerlich aus, aber damals war es ja völlig offen, wie so eine Waffe aussieht. Genau, aber das erste Flugding, was dieser Pilz war, auf die Flügel hin, das Ding war, das ist ein was man da sieht, wenn man die Ride-Brüder zeigt, wie die anfangen, das Flugzeug zu bauen, war der erste Versuch, die sind so ein Pilz und das Pilzdach, das geht ganz hoch.
Wie so ein grosser Sonnenschirm vielleicht. Ja genau, der Sonnenschirm geht ganz oft hoch und runter und dann dachte man, ist es leichter, dass es hoch geht und man verdrängt an Luft, wenn es nach unten geht. Was überhaupt nicht funktionieren kann. Du sitzt halt da drin in so einer kleinen Art Korb, so kann man sich vorstellen wie so ein heisser Ballon, und wirst die ganze Zeit hoch und runter geschüttelt, bis du wahnsinnig wirst, das Ding zerberstet und du tot bist. Und du bist die ganze Zeit nur hoch und runter gerissen. Was eine blöde Idee, dachte man so wirklich, ja, das ist es. Und stell dir mal vor, so würde man heute fliegen, da einfach so ein großes Logo Air Berlin drauf, und dann sitzt du die ganze Zeit im Flieger, Entschuldigung, wollen Sie noch einen Tomaten? Guckst Bärenbrüder 3D im Fernsehen, in diesem Bordfilm, Bordkino, isst irgendwie die schöne Pilkingsuppe, die du bekommst, fliegst aber in so einem Gefährt. Stell dir mal vor, das wäre die Lösung gewesen. Aber im Ernst, gäbe es davon keine Filmaufnahmen, wüssten wir davon nicht, weil die, die es erfunden haben, hätten das hundertprozentig verschwiegen, die Pläne vernichtet. Im Mittelalter, was die sich da für einen Scheiss ausgedacht haben mussten. Ey, ich würde so gerne, na, ich würde vielleicht doch eher in die Zukunft. Aber da wünsche ich manchmal so, der hat ja, es wurde ja alles geleakt von dem, auch die doofen Ideen. Ja. Und da ist auch viel Bullshit dabei. Das weiss er auch selber, der ist ja nämlich doof. Da ist ja viel Quatsch dabei und dachte sich manchmal so, das ist ja wie sein Tagebuch, er hat so ein kleines Skizzen gemacht und dann hat er auch mal so eine Frau gemalt und dann hat er auch mal ein bisschen rumgemalt hier. Ja, ja. Dachte er sich irgendwann so, shit, hätte ich mein Atelier besser abschliessen müssen. Ey, das ist eine Bild-Zeitungsüberschrift, die ich sehen will, und zwar, saudumme Idee von da Vinci entdeckt. Zwei Tausend Jahre nach seinem Tod entdeckten Forscher nun eine saudumme Idee von da Vinci entdeckt. Zweitausend Jahre nach seinem Tod entdeckte Forscher nun eine saudumme Idee von da Vinci. Selten dämlich. Was denkt der, so ganz grossen Caps, was denkt der sich, und dann drunter, da Vinci hat eine doofe Idee gehabt. Und dann so eine Facepalm-Emoji. Was hat er sich dabei gedacht? Bild. Was hat er sich dabei gedacht? Wie dumm kann man eigentlich sein? Dumm Vinci? Fragezeichen. Wohl eher Da Wischi Waschi. Das ist unsere Schlagzeile. Er hatte nicht nur gute Idee, was nicht.
Sau, saudumme Idee. Selten dämlich. Da Vinci-Skripte, alter Da Vinci-Skripte entdeckt.
Holler wie Waldfee, viel im Argen. Stockdumm. Dumm wie Brot! Da bin ich schick.
Ah, herrlich.
Ja, da war ja nicht alles perfekt.
War auch viel Quatsch.
Ah, das finde ich schön. Ey, die Schlagzeile, wie ich lesen.
Könnte man nicht so was faken mal?
Ich meine, das mit den Hitler-Tagebüchen hat super funktioniert. Da stelle ich mir sowieso so vor, die grossen Pranks der Geschichte, auch weil du vorhin von Yeti gesprochen hast. Es gibt ja dieses Loch Ness Bild, wo du tatsächlich diesen Kopf siehst und dann so den Schnauze und so und den Buckel und so. Und dann tatsächlich. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, bereits ein Scherz folgt. Tatsächlich wurden da viele Fotos gemacht und viele haben das als Anhaltspunkt genommen, um da hinzufahren, Loch Ness nach dem Monster zu suchen und wahnsinnig viele Sachen. Und dann irgend so ein Typ, der das Foto gemacht hat, am Sterbebett. Nee, das ist ein Miniaturmodell, das wir im Wasser gestellt haben und fotografiert haben. Ciao, tot. Genau so war es. Und wo ich mir denke, was für ein fucking Arschloch. Aber einerseits, es ist wahrscheinlich zu weit getrieben und der denkt sich, ich kann das jetzt nicht auflösen im Alter von 30 und bin ich den Räumen des Lebens der Trottel und am Sterbett sagt er, weißt du was? Ich habe mich ein bisschen verrannt. Crank! Was ein guter Abgang. Ja, vor allem, dass es niemand gesehen hat, dass es zu klein ist. So ein Ding muss ja riesengroß sein. Ich habe ja Journalismus studiert und es kamen so ein paar Situationen, wo man halt mal mit Leuten spricht, die beim WDR arbeiten und so, auch Leute, die beim Monitor arbeiten, so eine der krassesten Investigativ-Sendungen ja auch in Deutschland und so, die einfach Dinge leaken und die auch dann nicht mehr so trivial sind, die auch die Politik beeinflussen und so weiter.
Und wenn man mitbekommt, wie solche Leute, durch die man sein Wissen hat, du hast durch die Medien Wissen, durch nichts anderes, alles was du weisst, das ist dein Fernrohr in die Welt.
Wenn du weisst, wie das entsteht, fängst du an, an der Welt zu zweifeln. Weil es sind genauso Deppen wie wir, die keinen Bock haben, wenn die um zwölf Uhr ist und gleich Mittagspause ist, auch keinen Bock haben, mehr zu arbeiten, wollen aber auch eine geile Story haben, wollen auch Credits haben. Und halt auch so eine Pass-Storm-Mentalität haben. Und dann rufen die halt auch Leute an, von denen sie wissen, dass sie denen die Zitate geben, die sie wollen und so. Das ist einfach auch billig und so. Die wollen halt auch die geilste Story daraus machen. Und dann denke ich mir, so genau so müssen doch auch Historiker arbeiten. Die werden doch auch nur die Dinge veröffentlichen, von denen sie glauben, aha, das ist geil, wenn ich das rausfinde. Diese ganzen langweiligen Dinge, die es mal gab, die hat man doch komplett vergessen. Der Mensch ist doch dafür viel zu einfach gestrickt, als dass er uns wirklich mitteilt, was wirklich mal war. Deswegen glaube ich, alles war boring, die meiste Zeit war unfassbar langweilig, Hitler war gar nicht so schlimm, diese ganzen Schlachten, die waren nicht so brutal. Ich glaube, es war alles, alles war, man kommt mal alle ein bisschen runter. Ja, chillt man das scheiß Leben. Ich glaube aber auch, dass es einfach gewisse Sachen gibt, die sich auch nicht mehr ändern werden. Zum Beispiel wie die Dinosaurier so. Dinosaurier werden nicht mit Federn irgendwann dargestellt werden, Punkt, ist einfach nicht so. Und wenn du irgendwann rausfilmst, hey Leute, pass auf, Jesus hieß gar nicht Jesus, sondern Jona Bär und dann wird niemand sagen, oh, Justin, wir ändern jetzt auf allen Inschriften, auf allen unseren Tattoos, ändern wir es zu Justin, wird nicht passieren, Punkt. Man sagt einfach, ja, der hieß schon Jesus. Der hieß schon, ja, Jona Bär.
Ich wäre gerne in dem Kopf gewesen, wo die Entscheidung gefallen ist und die die Pro und Contra-Listee hätte ich gern gesehen, wo schliesslich Jona Bär als die beste Alternative auch rausgekommen ist. Die Frage ist, gegen wen hat Jona Bär gewonnen? Was war Plan B? Ja, da müssten wir jetzt in die Paralleldimension springen. Ich meine, es wird doch nicht... nicht... Fuck, was nehmen wir? Oh, fuck! Nehmen wir Junabär? Was sind die Alternative? Ich hab noch Janoschka, Rulli... Rullibut und Fananana. Fananana ist ganz geil. Ah, scheiße, hat mit Folge 13. Er hat Junabär schon gesagt, okay, fuck it, sorry, ich bin raus, abbrechen, abbrechen. Was sind das für riesige Fliegenmonster? Ja, aber es stimmt schon, ich glaube, der Mensch ist an Wahrheit auch überhaupt nicht interessiert. Was ist denn Wahrheit? Es ist ein Konstrukt, an dem niemand Interesse hat. Du willst, Wahrheit bringt dir doch nur was, wenn es dir was bringt. Im Endeffekt alles, alles ist Bullshit. Alles Bullshit. Ich habe noch nicht das lustigste Inter Radiointerview meines Lebens gehört. Ich bin so durch den Westen Deutschlands gefahren, WDR 2 gehört. Du sagst jetzt was, ne? Das lustigste deines Lebens. Radiointerview. Ich habe jetzt erst vier Radiointerviews gehört. So, und dann gab es im WDR 2, gab es dann eigentlich ein toller Sender. So, ein sehr profession, grosser Reilesender. Und dann war so ein Moderator, keine Ahnung, wer das war, wie der hieß. Und da hat er dann so eine 28, nee, so eine 28-31-jährige Frau zu Gast, die Professorin am MIT ist für Astronomie. Also eine unfassbare, und die hat sich spezialisiert auf Sterne. Und es war so unfassbar, wie schlau diese Person war. Und ich dachte mir, geil, so du fährst durch die Welt und plötzlich hast du so einen coolen Gesprächspartner. Ich dachte mir, geil, was würde ich für Fragen stellen, was will man von so einer Frau wissen und so. Und dann war es einfach der grösste, grösste Vollidiot, wo ich mir dachte, ja, wir sind einfach verloren. So, die Menschheit ist einfach verloren, weil das sind die schlauen Menschen, mit denen können wir nicht reden. Dann war halt, das war ein ausgebildeter Journalist, der hat sich dann hingesetzt und hat gesagt, ja, so, und du untersuchst jetzt diese Planeten oder was? Nee, Sterne, ja gut, aber das sind ja quasi Planeten, Sterne sind schon was anderes, die durch die Kernreaktionen, blablabla. Und dann hat er die ganze Zeit diese Fragen gestellt, er hat immer wieder Planete gesagt, er hat die ganze Zeit so Fragen gestellt wie, ja, und du hast ja jetzt neulich einen Stern entdeckt, dann heisst sie irgendwie Anne oder so, willst du den jetzt auch Anne nennen? Und die ganze Zeit hat nur solche Fragen gestellt und sie hat, nein, den müssten wir dann Beta, X, Y, Gamma, 3, C, 13, 12 nennen, weil aus dem und dem Grund, er hat die unterbrochen und hat gesagt, wenn du jetzt ein Kind hättest, würdest du das dann irgendwie, würdest du den Stern danach benennen, Luna, ist Luna ein Name, der für ein Kind hat die ganze Zeit solche Fragen gestellt, damit einfach fick dich, fick dich, fick dich, das kann nicht dann ernst sein gerade. Und ich fand die Vorstellung so gut, dass man einfach, dachte ich auch vielleicht nur so eine Serie, über so Leute, die einfach so unfassbar schlau sind und solche Dinge entdecken, aber die ganze Zeit nur halt dann mit Öffentlichkeit sprechen müssen, mit der Presse sprechen müssen, die ganze Zeit nur Deppen sind, die nicht begreifen können in ihren Gehirnen, was die schaffen, leisten und was mit denen los ist. Ich glaube, es muss so frustrierend sein, sich wirklich mit Dingen auszukennen, weil auch die ganze öffentliche Diskussion geht ja komplett am Thema vorbei. Weil du angenommen bist als Wissenschaftler und kennst dich brutal gut mit Klimawandel aus. Und du schaust dir die öffentliche Debatte an und du denkst dir wahrscheinlich, beide Seiten haben keine Ahnung, worum es geht. Alle Argumente sind falsch. Selbst die Argumente, die für meine Position sprechen, sind völlig falsch inhaltlich. Ihr habt keine Ahnung, worum es geht. Und die Fakten kommen nicht bei euch an. Ihr habt eine völlig falsche Vorstellung, wie die Welt funktioniert. Genau so einer wird entdecken, was los ist. Genau so einer wird entdecken, dass die Welt untergeht irgendwann. Und wir werden nicht auf diesen Menschen hören, weil das ein Vollidiot ist in unseren Augen. Aber am Ende entscheidet ja die Öffentlichkeit, weil die Politik steht ja nicht in der Verantwortung zu der Wissenschaft, sondern in der Verantwortung zu dem Volk. Und wenn das Volk sagt, riesige Proteste, Klimawandel ist eine Lüge, bla bla, dann sagt die Politik, ja, wir sind Volksvertreter, nicht Wissenschaftsvertreter, im Endeffekt ist es natürlich deren Aufgabe, zu einer gewissen Weise dann aufzusagen. Oh, Gesellschaftskitekt von Florentin Will, willst du Wissenschaftsvertreter haben? Willst du Wissenschaftsvertreter im Parlament haben? Ja, ja, ja, natürlich, ich hätte gerne eine Diktatur der Wissenschaft. Aristokratie? Zu sagen, sind die Reichen nicht, die wissen, klauen das Gutes. Apiokratie, die Klugen sollen herrschen und einfach sagen, Freunde, hört mal auf,
auch dieses ganze Meinungsgedödel, man muss nicht zu allen eine Meinung haben, ey, Leute,
weißt du, wenn dich jemand fragt, sag mal, was hältst du eigentlich vom Klimawandel,
dann wäre die richtige Antwort, müsste ich kurz nachlesen.
Einen Moment und dann nach zwei Minuten, lol, lustiges Video entdenkt.
Guck mal, die Katze hat eine Hose an, oi! Und schon hat sich die Sache eigentlich erledigt. Es gibt aber auch so lustige Videos. Es gibt so lustige Videos. Wirklich, es gibt so wahnsinnige Videos. Ja, wir wollten noch, was wollten wir am Anfang empfehlen? Warte mal, ich glaube, das sollte die grosse Empfehlung sein. Warte, warte, aber irgendwas kommt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das tatsächlich empfohlen haben oder nicht.
Also ich wollte kurz, kannst du darüber nachdenken?
Podcast?
Ich wollte einen Podcast empfehlen, und zwar Switched on Pop.
Ein mega interessanter, spannender Podcast für die Musikinteressierten unter euch.
Und zwar sind es zwei Musiker und Musikwissenschaftler, die halt sie die Top 100 durchgehen der amerikanischen Billboard--Charts und dann einfach die Popsongs raussuchen, die die für gut halten und die herausstechen. Und es sind meistens auch die Popsongs, die bei mir immer hängenbleiben und die, ja, wo ich mich dann schäme, die gut zu finden. Zum Beispiel Bad Liar von Selena Gomez, das ist glaube ich die letzte Folge jetzt auch, wo die darüber gesprochen haben und herausfinden, warum das ein guter Song ist, warum das einfach textlich und harmonisch und musikalisch einfach komplett Sinn macht und einfach ein gelungener, cooler Popsong ist. Und es ist so cool, das zu hören, weil die das erklären und du die ganze Zeit denkst, ja man, ja man, ja man. Und das ist so eine, also für Leute, die Musik interessiert sind und oder auch für Songtexte interessieren, mega, mega cooler Podcast, Switched on Pop. Switched on Pop. Ich würde jetzt wirklich gerne nochmal an Anfang springen
und nachhören, was ich da gesagt habe, weil ich habe das Gefühl,
dass sich jetzt ganz viele Leute...
Nee, du wolltest das empfehlen. Was wollte ich empfehlen?
Irgendwas, das ist die grosse Empfehlung.
Ja, aber ich habe irgendwas, wir haben über irgendwas
Konkretes gesprochen
und dann, wie hatten die Folge
angefangen? Das wir haben...
Video empfehlen vielleicht? Warte, wir haben doch irgendwas gesungen.
Was haben wir gesungen?
Was war der in der, ähm ...
Ich wollte ein Video empfehlen.
Hitler.
Serie, wolltest du eine Serie empfehlen?
Komm, wir spielen mal zurück.
Was wollte ich, was habe ich denn gerade für Tabs offen?
Hitler.
Hitler zwei. Fuck, können wir das machen? Ja. Okay, dann machen wir jetzt einen kurzen Zeitsprung. Gut, wir machen einen kurzen Zeitsprung. Ja, ich habe es mir gerade angehört, und zwar, wir haben angestimmt, dass unendlich viele Nachkommastellen hat die Eulersche Zahl, weil sich nichts immer wieder wiederholt, ist sie irrational. Einen Beweister und zwar genau jetzt weiss es wieder mein Gott. Fittiggrös, Dorfuchs, es gibt einen YouTuber, der heisst Dorfuchs, D-O-R und dann wie das Tier, Tier, wie das Tier von Team Man, Dorfuchs und der macht Videos und zwar kombiniert der Mathe mit Musik. Und das ist genial. Und es gibt diesen Song, ich glaube, das ist sogar sein klickstärkstes Video, das könnt ihr ja suchen, heißt Die Eulersche Zahl. Und es, vielleicht haben manche Hörer den Eindruck, ich würde mich über ihn lustig machen, aber das stimmt wirklich nicht. Ich finde es wirklich und ernsthaft richtig cool, was der Typ macht, weil es ist echt coole Musik und es ist irgendwie catchy und es ist cool und ich liebe es, wenn Leute so eine Hardcore-Leidenschaft für irgendwas haben und sagen, hey, ich mag Mathe und irgendwie Mathe ist ein bisschen trocken, aber ich gebe mir Mühe, das richtig cool zu machen und ich meine, wie fucking badass ist es denn, über die fucking binomischen Formeln zu rappen? Ich finde es richtig cool, wo viele so ... Originell. Klar, die sagen, der echte Hip-Hop ist für mich immer Money, Bitches und meine Eheprobleme. Und der andere Freund, die sagt, oh, echte Mathe, die gehört aus Papier und die gehört noch geschrieben mit einem Füller und einem Kulli auf Kasten. Deswegen schaut es euch mal an. Okay. Dorfuchs, lasst ein paar Kommis da. Vielleicht kann man irgendwann eine Kooperation machen zwischen Dorfuchs und dem Podcast. Ey, wenn er Bock hat, dann unser beider Favorit, der beste Filmkritiker und der einzige ernstzunehmende Filmkritiker Deutschlands, Wolfgang M. Schmidt. Absolut. Bei Filmanalyse, bei YouTube, natürlich kein Geheimtipp mehr, glaube ich mittlerweile, obwohl er auch zu viel Ziemlich Abonnenten hat. Er ist der grosse große Nachvolle. Marcel Reich-Ranitzki ist tot, Joachim Kaiser ist tot und der Nächste in diesen grossen Spuren ist Wolfgang M. Schminzio.
Ich würde mich auf das Fenster lehnen und sagen, alle anderen kannst du vergessen.
In Deutschland kannst du alle anderen komplett vergessen.
Dann ein großer Tipp von mir, und zwar heißt der Mann THG Petersen.
Das ist ein Lehrer, der von dem Theodor-Heuss-Gymnasium, der Mann heißt Petersen, ist offensichtlich ein Mathe-LK-Lehrer. Und der Mann ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr zwar animierte Videos, indem er He-Man zu Mathe-Man macht. und Mathe-Mann und Mathe-Katze. Mathe-Mann und Mathe-Katze lösen gemeinsam, und es ist so, also die lösen halt gemeinsam irgendwelche Rätsel,
und oft sind Lösungen, wie binomische Formeln, sind dann das Schlüssel. Und Mathe-Mann und Mathe-Katze. Mathe-Mann und Mathe-Katze lösen gemeinsam, und es ist so ...
Also die lösen halt gemeinsam irgendwelche Rätsel, und oft sind Lösungen, wie binomische Formeln, sind dann das Schlüsselt, um die Prinzessin zu retten und so.
Und es ist so mindblowing lustig, also oft so ein ganz eigener Humor, aber der Mann hat so viel Stil dafür, dass er offensichtlich Lehrer ist und diese Videos nur nebenbei raushaut, wie diese Schüler, die auch oft in Videos drin vorkommen und vor die Kamera gezerrt werden, wie irgendwas lernen ist, komplett schleierhaft, wie die das Abitur bestehen konnten, komplett schleierhaft. Aber der Mann macht ganz viele Videos, die sind alle lustig und das zieht sich einfach so ein roter Humorfaden durch, den ich so beeindruckend finde. Viele Dinge verstehe ich nicht, weil es Insider sind, habe trotzdem herzhaft gelacht, aber ganz, ganz toll. Also Shoutout an an THG Peterson. Geil. Ich habe auch noch eine Empfehlung, haue ich noch raus, ein bisschen was in der nerdigeren Ecke, und zwar Red Letter Media. Ja. Habe ich mir in der letzten Zeit mal ein bisschen reingehört. Es ist ein echt abgefahrener Kanal, der bekannt geworden ist durch seine mehrteiligen Kritiken zu Star Wars, Episode eins und Episode zwei. Richtig cool, ein richtig cooler Haufen Leute, die einen weirden Humor haben und sich sehr intensiv und hardcore mit Popkultur und Videospielen und Filmen beschäftigen und es macht einfach Spaß. Von denen kriegst du keine, du wirst enttäuscht manchmal von denen, weil die halt so viel Style haben. Die machen auch keine Trailer Reviews oder Trailer Breakdowns und so einen ganzen Bullshit. Die haben irgendwie ihren ganz eigenen Kosmos und Medienimperium im kleinen Stil aufgebaut. Ist so ein bisschen auch Satire von Dingen, also die nehmen oft Dinge durchs Korn, die sich mittlerweile auf YouTube so etabliert haben, wie so Trailer-Breakdowns und so. Die haben einen ganzen eigenen Stil, behaupten immer viele Dinge, man muss sich da auch ewig reingucken, bis man ein bisschen was versteht. Es ist manchmal bewusst trashig, es ist aber immer sehr lustig und es sind immer unglaublich lange Videos, man kann sich da wirklich drin verlieren. Er ist richtig cool, aber schaut es euch an, wenn ihr Bock habt, so ein bisschen in so eine andere Nerd-Ebene zu steigen, von richtigen coolen Leuten, Red Letter Media. Ja, super gut. Das waren die Empfehlungen. Ey, ey, ey, ey, ey, Alter, ey, absolut. Ich sag's dir mal. Ey, wir müssen auch ein bisschen andere Leute supporten. Ich sag es immer, hab ich immer schon gesagt. Ach, andere Leute sind auch ganz gut manchmal. Und da habt ihr jetzt die Möglichkeit, euch ein bisschen um andere Leute zu kümmern oder mal selber ein paar geile Sachen rauszuhauen. Wenn ihr geil seid, werden wir euch empfehlen, vielleicht mal so ein bisschen das große Podcast-Uvo-Nachwuchsspektakel, wo wir einfach mal ein bisschen YouTube-Kanäle, die weniger als 50 Abonnenten haben und das supporten. Haut mal was raus, haut mal ein paar geile Sachen raus und viel Spaß mit deinen Empfehlungen. Viel Spaß, vor allem mit der ganzen nächsten Woche, denn die werdet ihr ohne uns verbringen. Jetzt ist die ganze Woche wieder da und wir kommen erst nächste Woche wieder, um mich zu bespaßen. Alte Folgen könnt ihr immer hören, Antenne Alderaan ist noch offen, ganz viele tolle Folgen. Der Seed In-Time ist noch da, Lacast ist da, immer toll, andere Folgen, cool. Viel viel
Spaß mit der Woche, viel Spaß mit dem echten Leben, viel Spaß mit eurem Leben, es beginnt jetzt. Stefan Tietze, ciao, wir heben ab.